Trump stays silent as Hong Kong faces
down Chinese authoritarianism the bond
yields invert and somebody allegedly
shoots up a nice facility I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man a lot to get to today and not very
much of it good news but we will get
through all of it together don't worry
it's a normal day just like any other
and together we will soldier through we
get to all of that in just one second
first there are a thousand different
types of cars on the road I mean you
just look around at the cars on the road
and you will quickly realize that if you
wanted to buy a part for any one of
those specific cars you'd be very
difficult to do so by going to your
local auto parts store the chances that
they are completely in stock on the part
that you need very very low and this is
where Rock Auto calm comes in you know
you want to order the exact part that
you need online rather than wait in line
in a store for a part that probably
ain't gonna fit properly anyway or do
the best job Rock auto solves that
problem for you it's a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to Rock Auto calm I'm shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver you can get everything you need
and a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door the rockauto.com catalog is
super easy to navigate you can quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and filter by brand
specifications and prices best of all
the price is over at rockauto.com
are always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts at your car
will ever need rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for the car truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
again right shapiro in that how did you
hear about us box and then they'll know
that we say it helps them helps us go to
Rock Auto calm all righty so the stock
market is down again today it is down
again on fears about the future of the
trade war on slowdowns in the German
economy on slowdowns in the in the
Chinese economy particularly Chinese at
manufacturing sector as of this morning
the Dow Jones Industrial Average had
dropped over 400 points it was it was
down nearly 2% the Nasdaq was down
nearly 2% a lot of uncertainty about the
markets and a lot of that is being
triggered also by the fact that the main
yield curve had just inverted this is
the first time this has happened
since 2007 the last three times that the
yields curve has inverted that has
prefaced a recession so people are
getting really worried at this point
according to CNBC calm the yield on the
benchmark 10-year Treasury note broke
below the 2-year rate early on Wednesday
an odd bond market phenomenon that has
been reliable I'll be an early indicator
for economic recessions the yield on
u.s. 30-year bonds fell to an all-time
low
dropping past its prior record notched
in summer of 2016 the moves show
increasing worries about the global
economy as investors rush into safe
havens how normally what you would
expect is that you get a lower yield on
short term bonds than you do on long
term bonds and that just makes perfect
sense I mean the fact is that you're
going to want more in return for storing
your money with the government for 30
years then you'd want for storing your
money with the government for five but
when people have very little hope for
the future of the stock market or
alternative investments the yield in the
near term starts to drop on bonds people
start to run to bonds as safe-haven the
yields start to drop on short-term bonds
and it continues to remain at the level
it was for long-term bonds and that's
when the yield curve so-called inverts
that is a sign of deep and surprising
mistrust in the strength of the global
economy at this point early on Wednesday
the yield on the benchmark ten-year
Treasury note was at 1.6 to 3 percent
below the 2-year yield at one point 6 3
4 percent in practice that means that
investors are better compensated for
loaning the US over 2 years than they
are for loaning for 10 years again
that's because they don't want alone for
two years right so the government has to
incentivize them to loan for two years
by offering them higher rates so this is
this is not a good sign for the economy
and this comes in the midst of a lot of
trade tension between the United States
and China that trade tension has been
ratcheted up by the Trump administration
not for national security reasons
purportedly but for economic reasons so
President Trump came into office on the
back of a promise to restore some sort
of trade balance between the United
States and China as it turns out the
tariffs that he has imposed have
actually exacerbated the trade imbalance
between the United States and China
they've not made things all that much
better and they have resulted in less
Chinese investments in US assets because
after all why would China invest in US
assets in the middle of a tariff or so
what we've seen is a slowdown in protect
sectors of the economy agriculture being
the chief one but also in manufacturing
in the United States and this came
before the hubbub between China and Hong
Kong so just a few weeks ago well rather
a couple of months ago this this
controversy broke into the open
regarding Hong Kong which wanted to
reassert some of its long-standing
rights against the Chinese government
when the British government left Hong
Kong made a deal with China the idea was
that Hong Kong was still going to retain
a heavy degree of Independence China has
repeatedly violated that the people of
Hong Kong are sick of it and millions of
them have been chanting in the streets
marching in the streets carrying
American flags calling for more civil
liberties and more freedom and China has
responded with a crackdown and now the
only question is how harsh that
crackdown is going to be according to
the New York Times as of yesterday
anti-government protesters clashed with
Hong Kong riot police on Tuesday
crippling the airport for the second
straight day targeting a potent symbol
of the city's position as a global
center of commerce and finance that is
essential to China the mass protests
have forced the airport to suspend
check-ins creating long delays for
passengers and forcing airlines to
cancel hundreds of flights over the past
few days after a chaotic night check-ins
resumed on Wednesday morning the airport
warned that flights would be rescheduled
Hong Kong's flagship carrier said there
would be a further flight disruption at
short notice the protest at the airport
had been deeply tactical as the largely
leaderless movement strikes at the vital
economic artery according to the New
York Times Hong Kong International
Airport which opened in 1998 a year
after China reclaimed the territory from
Britain serves as a gateway to the rest
of Asia sleek and well-run the airport
accommodates nearly 75 million
passengers per year
protesters are trying to intensify
pressure on the government which has
refused to meet their demands after
earlier efforts to occupy local roads
shopping malls and parks failed to
produce concessions they decided to
shift their efforts to a more global
stage and there the protesters are
handing out pamphlets in different
languages explaining their position the
protesters say their other tactics are
not working and that other countries
aren't paying attention to any of this
clashes began late Tuesday evening after
a group of demonstrators attacked a man
they accused of being a mainland Chinese
police officer impersonating a protester
which would not be surprising the
Chinese have apparently been attempting
to infiltrate some of the protests and
medics and police try as medics and
tried to evacuate him in an ambulance
protesters blocked a road outside the
department Hall the departure hall
rather some officers in riot gear then
began running after demonstrators
wrestling some to the ground a group of
protesters inside surrounded a police
officer taking his baton and then
beating him with it and they were
treated after he pulled a gun here is
what that actually looked like Hong Kong
protests really did get violent
it stars got quite ugly he could have
gotten a lot uglier if this police
officer had pulled his gun and shot
somebody right now the Chinese
government is trying to portray the
protesters who have been nearly entirely
peaceful as rioters they've been trying
to portray them as rabble rousers who
are trying to stand up to the Chinese
government in illegal ways according to
the Washington Post after late-night mob
scenes martyr demonstration that
paralyzed the city's airport protesters
on Wednesday issued apologies seeking
the international public's sympathy and
forgiveness as they fought to regain
control over a narrative that seemed to
be tilting in Beijing's favor for the
first time the appeals included
apologies to the police force and come
as struggle over public opinion reaches
a climax while Hong Kong's protest
movement has become stetic aesthetically
radicalized and fractured the Chinese
government is ramping up its own
propaganda effort in state media and on
social networks attempting to discredit
and deflate a movement that to this
point enjoyed wide support across Hong
Kong society the Chinese government is
now labeling the protesters rioters and
they say that they are asking for
self-destruction military vehicles have
been baba had been massing nearby
president from tweeted that out
yesterday he said our intelligence has
informed us that the Chinese government
is moving troops to the border with Hong
Kong everyone should be calm and safe
meanwhile the city's embattled leader
Carrie Lam told the news media on Friday
the law-breaking activities in the name
of freedom are damaging the rule of law
and that the Asian financial hubs
recovery from anti-government protests
could take a long time so this could be
used as a as an excuse for even more of
a crackdown on the people of Hong Kong
now what you would want here is for the
United States take a strong position and
the fact is that if we have a tenant in
Tiananmen Square type event here the
United States is going to have to take
strong trade action and president Trump
has not been shy about talking about
taking that sort of action I said now in
the very recent past meeting in the last
48 hours he seems to be backing off all
of that and he seems to be backing off
all of that because he's finally
realizing that his tariffs hurt the
American economy now as I've been saying
for months the only way for the
president to make the case for his
tariffs is to make them on national
security grounds you cannot make a case
for a tariff on economic grounds tariffs
do not help the domestic economy they
are attacks on American citizens they
hurt consumers
president Trump finally recognizing this
as Christmas approaches and as the
economy seems to be possibly tipping
into recession certainly into economic
slowdown the New York Times reports that
yesterday president Trump unexpectedly
put off new tariffs on many Chinese
goods including cell phones laptop
computers and toys until after the start
of the Christmas shopping season
acknowledging the effect that his
protracted trade war with Beijing could
have on Americans so Trump has been
fibbing to you the entire time
with regard to tariffs he said the trade
wars were easy to win and good for the
economy neither of those is true it
turns out the Beijing does not care
about its billion citizens nearly as
much as Trump cares about the domestic
economy here in the United States what's
more Trump said that it would be good
for the economy no tariffs are a tax on
American citizens they hurt American
consumers and Trump is now acknowledging
that so to fail to recognize that Trump
is now switching his position on this
would be dishonest Trump pushed to 10%
tariffs on some imports to December 15th
excluded others from it entirely while
facing mounting pressure from business
and consumer groups over the harm they
say the trade conflict is doing Trump
explained quote just in case they might
have an impact on people what we've done
is delayed is that they won't be
relevant for the Christmas shopping
season a that is a full-scale
acknowledgement by Trump that tariffs
hurt American consumers Trump is
frustrated that negotiations have failed
to yield an agreement he said on August
1st the US would impose a ten percent
tariff on three hundred billion dollars
worth of Chinese imports September 1st
that would be in addition to a 25%
tariff already imposed on 250 billion
dollars of Chinese goods well Trump
painted himself into a corner I mean
there's that's really what happened here
Trump painted himself into a corner and
now with the economy on the brink of a
of a slowdown this is put President
Trump in a very difficult position it's
put him in a position where if he takes
a strong stand against China it could in
fact damage his re-election prospects in
a serious way and so in a time when we
should be ratcheting up the possibility
of economic sanctions we're actually
ratcheting down the possibility of
economic sanctions whereas before when
we should have been negotiating a trade
deal we should invested it the
trans-pacific partnership we should have
renegotiated it it was a mistake to exit
TPP which is a trade deal directed
against the economic strength of China
in Asia the all the lies about the TPP
that it was good for China was a lie TPP
was designed explicitly as a
counterbalance to Chinese infiltration
economically in the region you know in a
time when we should have been looking
for a trade deal we were searching
instead for trade conflicts in a time
when we should be ratcheting up trade
conflict as a as an effect of trying to
help the Hong Kong protesters we're not
doing any of that and so this has led
President Trump to this bizarre kind of
halfway position on Hong Kong so in the
last 24 hours he's tweeted out quote as
usual China said they were going to be
buying big from our great American
farmers so far they have not done what
they said maybe this will be different I
don't know the hell that means
and then he added quote many are blaming
me and the United States for the
problems going on in Hong Kong I can't
imagine why okay again Trump is not
responsible for what's going on in Hong
Kong but this would be a time for him to
stand up for freedom in an area of the
world that deserves it
had negotiated for it and now is not
receiving it from what is a geopolitical
enemy of the United States China
stealing our technology building rival
5g networks that attempt to provide a
counterbalance to the 5g networks we are
building right now we are in a second
Cold War with the Chinese
it will stay cold we can all hope but
the fact is that the Chinese are an
expansionist power and they have been
both militarily and technologically they
are doing so at the expense of the
United States and the United States if
we're going to take harsh action against
China you need to make the case now
Trump has converted he keeps making this
sort of weird case where Xi Jinping is
his best friend and we're great we're
gonna negotiate a deal together and then
at the same time the Chinese keep
jacking us and the Chinese are the worst
and they're cheating us and they're
stealing our manufacturing jobs explain
what it is you are doing president Trump
if you want the American people to be
with you and especially again in the
midst of a time when there are
protesters in the streets in Hong Kong
who may be mowed down by the Chinese
government in the very near future this
would be a time for you to stand up and
say this is why we have been putting
tariffs on China it's because of crap
like this that we've been putting
tariffs on China and as JFK put it we
will bear any burden in the name of
Liberty and I'm sorry but getting
slightly more expensive goods from China
in the name of Liberty
doesn't seem like all that much of a
burden to bear to help the people of
Hong Kong who are flying the American
flag while they are protesting for their
freedom but that's not the kind of
statement that Trump is making right now
a Barack Obama back in 2009 had the
opportunity to stand with protesters
against the Iranian regime and instead
he completely undercut them and he
suggested that it was an Iranian
internal problem and the protesters
remote down in the streets and the
Iranian government instead got a
sweetheart deal from the American
government it was disgusting you don't
want the same thing from the Trump
administration with regard to China if
they should run roughshod over the
protesters for human rights and
democracy in Hong Kong
Trump's only statement with regard to
Hong Kong directly he said our
intelligence has informed us that the
Chinese government is moving troops to
the border with Hong Kong everyone
should be calm and safe yeah that's not
exactly a ringing endorsement of the
protesters aims here in fact it's it's
pretty milquetoast and the Trump was
elected for his tough-talking on a
second I want to talk about the
practicality versus the versus the moral
character question in foreign policy
because I understand what president
Trump's defenders on this score are
gonna say well get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the post
office so I honestly kind of like the
post office but the fact is last time I
went to the post office I ran inside for
five minutes I came back out there's a
parking ticket there are dangers
attendant to parking outside of a post
office in Los Angeles namely that the
only efficient part of Los Angeles
government is not removing the trash
from the streets removing the open
needles from the streets or making sure
that homeless people don't sleep under
every single overhang know what they are
great at is the traffic it's fantastic
at it so my deal not going to the post
office again instead I use stamps calm
stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps calm you get
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a
we crowd plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on that microphone at
the top of the home page type in promo
code Shapiro that stamps calm and use
Shapiro to get that special deal
four-week trial free postage digital
scale no long-term commitment hell of a
deal Shapiro enter it in the top of the
homepage on a microphone when you go to
stamps calm okay so president Trump was
asked about the Hong Kong situation
verbally and here is what Trump had to
say
okay so the case for Trump doing this is
that he doesn't want to make trade
negotiations harder he's not willing to
take any explicit action against Hong
Kong the practicality overcomes morality
but the fact is that even by trumpian
standards this is really kind of bizarre
and weak it is not up to Trump's power
like Trump doesn't even he doesn't seem
to understand necessarily what's even
what seems to be in dispute when he says
the Hong Kong thing is a very tough
situation very tough we'll see what
happens that's sort of his normal Trump
patois pablum
the sort of normal Trump Ian PAP for
what he's asked a question that he
doesn't really know anything about and
he sort of just mumbles about it now
this would be the time when Trump should
stand up with the protesters in fact his
own administration they're members of
his own administration who are being a
lot more clear about this a senior
administration official recently told
CNBC quote freedom of expression and
assembly are core values we share with
the people of Hong Kong those freedoms
should be protected the u.s. firmly
rejects the notion that we are
sponsoring or inciting at the
demonstrations again
that is sort of splitting the baby a
little bit but what you have seen from
Mitch McConnell what you have seen from
Nancy Pelosi what you've seen across the
political aisle is a general support for
the protesters you're not seeing that
from the Trump administration now people
are gonna say again that's a practical
move by President Trump what he expect
him to do go to war with China or arm
the protesters no one's talking about
that but again this is a guy who
declared a trade war with China on the
basis of them supposedly shooting us
would it not behoove him to make similar
threats with regards to them running
roughshod over protesters that if they
should trash their own protesters if
they should kill a bunch of protesters
run them over with tanks or something
that the United States will take harsh
and appropriate non-military action
economic sanctions action that we
certainly will do right you Trump is not
gonna sit still for that so wouldn't you
want to issue some sort of threat at
this point issues some sort of form of
support for the Hong Kong protesters no
practicality and and moral and moral
rhetoric do not have to be on opposite
sides Ronald Reagan was able to call the
Soviet Union an evil empire even as he
was negotiating with them so this weird
notion that you have to either kowtow at
or
to a country or go to war with them is
just not proved by anything American
history
very often the very people we are
negotiating with are the people that we
are speaking most harshly about in order
to bring them to the table Trump likes
to kind of wheedle people into deals but
his wheedling hasn't produced a deal
with North Korea I understand that
everybody is very up on from
negotiations with North Korea they've
produced nothing literally nothing
except the legitimation of the
legitimization of the North Korean
regime that's it so before we get into
the this is a master class in
negotiation how about we see some good
results from one of these negotiations
and then you can talk about the master
class in fact the areas where Trump
actually has accomplished something with
negotiating tactics are the areas where
he has been the harshest with regard to
Mexico for example he was able to
negotiate a quasi immigration deal with
Mexico to keep many illegal immigrants
in Mexico to have him strengthen their
own southern border he did that by
threatening them we had President Trump
is more effective when he is the
braggadocious bully that he typically is
not when he is doing me wheedling
glad-handing routine with dictators in
Turkey or China or anywhere else on the
planet it's a bad look it's a it really
is a nasty look now meanwhile the media
continued to push forward the idea that
President Trump's rhetoric is inherently
awful and violent this is the the
narrative that they continue to push and
it's really kind of ridiculous okay so
truck listen when Trump says stuff that
I think is disgusting as I have said
many times pretty much every day I will
call it out but the media are now
running with the idea that he is
responsible for acts of violence across
the country and the way they are doing
this is by falsifying the statistics
this has become part of the democratic
2020 patch so there's a coordinated
pitch between the Democrats 2020 and the
media I'm not saying they're formally
coordinating this I'm saying that the
media are a democratic party outlet and
they and mainstream media spend an awful
lot of time parroting Democratic talking
points so it is no coincidence that even
as Democrats argue that Trump is
responsible for the El Paso shooting the
media are picking up on that and they
are running with it so for example
you've got beta O'Rourke who's going to
deliver a campaign reset speech on
Thursday which is hilarious right beta
been in the race for just a few months
he's already had two campaign resets
apparently he's going to deliver his
first major written address on Thursday
well good for him as Steven Miller not
the Steven Miller from the
administration but another Steven Miller
put it on Twitter and I'm playing a
sold-out concert in my living room like
who cares that bid O'Rourke making a
major campaign speech is like me making
a major campaign speech I'm not running
and really neither is he but apparently
he's delivering a major campaign speech
and you can guess exactly what it's
about it's about how Trump is a horrible
no-good terrible very very bad man
according to NBC News
former Texas representative O'Rourke
plans to deliver that first major
written address on Thursday offering a
reset of his presidential campaign the
wheels fell off the skateboard bra a new
focus and fresh strategy for going
forward in the wake of a mass shooting
in O'Rourke's hometown O'Rourke will
recommit to holding president Trump
accountable for the state of the country
and focus on the stakes of removing a
president from office whom he has
explicitly linked to the deaths of
fellow El Paso ins according to a senior
campaign official he'll focus heavily on
three key issues racism white supremacy
and guns and plans to propose what the
campaign calls new bold solutions the
new bold solutions involve beta O'Rourke
going on TV and talking about these
things while waving his hands wildly
like a bizarre wind bill but that's his
that's his solution okay but the media
are ready to they're all in on that
particular narrative so Mike Levine
reporting remember this isn't an opinion
piece reporting for ABC News
he says this is the headline no blame
ABC news finds 36 cases invoking Trump
in connection with violence threats and
alleged assault
so Trump is responsible for all of the
violence and all of the threats and all
of these alleged to 36 of them by the
way
last I checked they're like 330 million
people in the country so 36 crimes in
which people invoked Trump in a court
proceeding okay I'm spare me the wave of
trumpian violence racking the nation
there's not a lot of evidence for that
and as we'll see from this particular
study the study itself is skewed to
achieve a particular result and you can
tell that I mean this is a case example
of media bias it's pretty it's pretty
stunning I'll get to that in just one
second first then they're there a lot
of options when you go to the store and
get you need shaving products you go to
the store and just tons of shaving what
you don't know which ones are good you
don't know which ones are bad many of
them are overpriced you know it'd be
great not having to go to the store at
all and this is where Dollar Shave Club
comes in Dollar Shave Club helps make
your life easier
taking out the guesswork and
guaranteeing quality shaving products
they've got really fantastic products
they got this executive razor I use it
under my jawline but they've also got
fantastic shave butter they've got all
sorts of soaps and shampoos they have
this amber lavender body cleanser that
it's just delightful I mean it is
calming and soothing Dollar Shave Club
has way more than just the razor they've
got you covered head to toe they've got
everything you need to shower shave
style your hair brush your teeth it is a
one-stop shop for all of your grooming
needs and Dollar Shave Club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use here enough to wait until you
run out and then you're in the shower
one day and you look down there's no
shampoo no icon damn it not have to use
soap in my hair instead you will be
constantly stocked up on all the
products that you want as a Dollar Shave
Club member I know that I'm going to
receive regular shipments of the stuff
that I want and what I'm getting is the
highest quality right now you can put
the quality of Dollar Shave club's
products to the test their ultimate
shave starter set has basically
everything you need for an amazing shave
they've got the executive razor shave
butter prep scrub post shave do the best
part you can try for just five bucks and
then the restock box ships regular size
products at regular prices so go get the
ultimate starter set for just five bucks
at dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
that's dollarshaveclub.com so I spent
once more dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
okay in just one second we're going to
get to this this insane piece from ABC
News accusing president Trump of a wide
swath of violence across the country and
explore how the media liked to bias this
particular case again Trump has raised
the temperature in the country the
temperature was already quite hot
politically and Trump cannot be blamed
for these acts of violence any more than
Bernie Sanders can be blamed for a
Congressional baseball shooting ABC new
tries to parse it I'll explain in just
one second first you have to go over to
Daley wire.com and subscribe when you do
then you get all sorts of goodies you
get the leftist here's how to call
tumblr for 9 for 99 bucks a year the
annual subscription it's fantastic you
also get access behind the scenes you
get to ask me questions in the mailbag
you get to
get early access to our events you got
two additional hours of the show I mean
for goodness sake I'm working my tail
off for you here
all you have to do is go subscribe you
get this look we even brought it on the
road the very greatest and beverage
vessels that leftist here's how to call
tumblr look at that we always bring it
on the road but this time I have
deactivated the cloaking device that we
normally use on the road to keep it safe
so it's an amazing piece of vessel where
I mean just incredible it's like the
holy grail of political vessel wear so
go check that out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
me so this ABC news piece tries to blame
President Trump for all kinds of
violence again the title of the piece no
blame
ABC News finds 36 cases invoking Trump
in connection with violence threats and
alleged assault and here's what the
piece says that again this is journalism
in of the highest order serious serious
journalism it says President Trump has
repeatedly refused to accept any
responsibility for inciting violence in
American communities dismissing critics
who have pointed to his rhetoric as a
potential source of inspiration for some
citizens acting on even long-held
beliefs of bigotry and hate I think my
rhetoric brings people together he said
last week four days after a 21 year old
allegedly posted an anti-immigrant
screed online and then allegedly opened
fire at a Walmart in El Paso Texas
killing 22 and injuring dozens of others
but a nationwide review conducted by ABC
News has identified at least 36 criminal
cases where Trump was invoked in direct
connection with violent acts threats of
violence or allegations of assault wow
36 criminal acts in a country of 336 is
330 million people and an
extraordinarily polarized time shocking
but here's here's what really gets good
listen to how they did this analysis in
nine cases perpetrators hailed Trump in
the midst or immediate aftermath of
physically attacking innocent victims
yes all that's evil and bad in another
ten cases perpetrators cheered or
defended Trump while taunting or
threatening others and in another ten
cases trumpet in his rhetoric were cited
in court to explain of defendants
violent or threatening behavior into
those last 10 cases very often what you
see in those cases is defense counsel
trying to make an overt pitch for media
attention and sympathy based on their
client invoking Trump after the fact and
so I don't trust any of that if there
was no prior evidence that the attack
was linked to anything Trump had said or
did Trump if there was no shouting of
Trump in the middle of the attack and
then afterward the defense attorney was
like yeah it was it was just like
frontman it's cuz it cuz of Trump I
don't buy it I don't buy it so take that
birdie 69 to 26 hey seven cases involves
violence or threatening acts perpetrated
in defiance of Trump with many of them
targeting Trump's allies in Congress so
that means that really it's not 36 is 26
and now you're talking about 7 of the 26
are actually
rats or violent acts targeting Trump
okay but it gets even better
they say the 36 case is identified by
ABC News are remarkable and that a link
to our president is captured in court
documents and police statements under
penalty of perjury or contempt in many
cases of assault or threat charges are
never filed criminal acts committed by
Trump supporters or his detractors have
nothing to do with the president but in
36 cases court records and police
reports indicated some sort of link and
they say of course these are mostly hate
crimes these are directed against
minority people and this is where it
gets really good and while asserting
that a fake media coverage is
exacerbating divisions in the country
Trump has noted that a fan of Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
opened fire on Republican lawmakers
playing baseball in Washington suburb
two years ago nobody puts Bernie Sanders
in the headline with the maniac Trump
said last year and last week Trump
similarly insisted that the man who
fatally shot nine people in Dayton Ohio
three days earlier supported Sanders and
other liberal causes but there's no
indication either of these shooters
mentioned Sanders while launching their
attacks and no charges were ever filed
because they were both fatally shots
during the assaults okay so you are now
changing the standards of crime okay so
first of all I agree the Dayton Ohio
shooter there's nothing that connects
his politics to the shooting so far that
we know of we know that he was on the
political left but we have to be
intellectually fair and honest here
there's no indicator that his politics
drove the shooting with that said the
shooting that the Congressional baseball
shooting was obviously an anti Trump Pro
Bernie Sanders shooting and there's just
no question about that the reason there
is no question about that is because the
day before he committed the shooting he
posted a bunch of crap on social media
about how much he hated Trump and Trump
supporters and then he wasn't shot
explicitly Republicans and here's ABC
News trying to contend that it had
nothing to do with Bernie Sanders
because the guy wasn't shouting Saunders
as he committed the assault it's absurd
and then wait caused him better again
ABC News really doing serious journalism
in here in conducting its review
ABC News did find several cases where
pro Trump defendants were charged with
targeting minorities or were a
speculation online suggested the
defendants were motivated by Trump but
in those cases ABC News found no police
records court proceedings or other
direct evidence presented
linked to the president so those were
excluded so they excluded also ABC News
excluded incidents of vandalism
okay well that's kind of a thing because
I would say that a huge amount of
vandalism across the country right now
is anti-trump vandalism also ABC News
excluded several cases of violence from
attacks on anti-trump protesters at
Trump rallies to certain assaults on
people wearing Magga hats that did not
establish explicit ties to trump so just
to be straight about this if somebody
attacks somebody at a trump rally or
beat up somebody wearing a Maggie hat
they didn't count that so so basically
you went looking for cases where he
could blame Trump and you found some
cases where he could blame Trump
congratulations guys
really solid stuff solid stuff a it's no
wonder that so many people on the right
buy into Trump's characterization of the
media and again you're not seeing the
media ask the very difficult questions
with regard to left-leaning rhetoric
because they agree with the left so over
the last 48 hours there was an attempted
shooting at another ice office San
Antonio Police according to the National
Review are questioning a man who's
suspected of shooting at downtown office
buildings occupied by ice according to a
local CBS affiliate police responded to
reports of gunshots around 3:00 a.m.
Tuesday morning the suspect fired at the
building from across the street
damaging several windows according to
police no one was harmed in the incident
police are investigating whether the
shooter intentionally targeted the ice
office that of course comes roughly one
month after the most unrecovered story
of the year a lone gunman trying to blow
up an ice detention facility in Tacoma
Washington armed with a rifle and
throwing incendiary devices at the
facility while trying to blow up a
propane tank nearby here is AOC by the
way asked whether she regrets the
concentration camp language which is
which was in fact explicitly used by the
ice attack or a month ago anything else
he says no I don't regret that at all
not in slightest do you feel on Israel
you said this administration is
established concentration camps on the
southern border of the United States for
immigrants where they are being
brutalized in dehumanizing conditions
and dying you got a lot of grief for
using the word concentration camps do
you regret that or do you think
yeah well I think I think there's a
there's a few things that play one I
don't regret it at all okay so she
doesn't regret it at all not at all and
nobody's gonna ask real serious
follow-up questions linking her to any
sort of violence of course well the ABC
News making sure that there is the
narrative that Trump is causing swathes
of violence across the country when in
reality the evidence for that is scanty
and then we'll see the left trying to
defend AOC as the brightest and wisest
among us and Bernie Sanders has nothing
to do with the Congressional baseball
shooter even if Trump is responsible for
El Paso or some such silliness like that
again this is why people on the right
don't trust the media another great
example of why people on the right don't
trust the media so today there's a big
controversy over Ken Cuccinelli Ken
Cuccinelli is the is the acting US
Citizenship and Immigration Services
director former senatorial candidate in
Virginia and he was on CNN and he was
asked about the the immigration policy
of the Trump administration which was
recently changed to make it difficult
for legal immigrants to stay in the
United States if they were on public
welfare which makes perfect sense we
don't want to admit people but are
simply going to live on the dole this
doesn't no sovereign country can do that
and hope to survive as a sovereign
entity and well cuccinelli was asked
about that on CNN and then the media
slandered him wretched poor refuse right
that's what the poem says America is
supposed to stand for so what do you
think America stands for well of course
that poem was referring back to people
coming from Europe where they had
class-based societies where people were
considered wretched if they weren't in
the right class and it was introduced it
was written one year one year after the
first federal public charge rule was
written that says and I'll quote it any
person unable to take care of himself
without becoming a public charge unquote
would be inadmissible he the way that
the media covered this is that
cuccinelli is saying that the original
poem was written only to apply to
European citizens who wanted to emigrate
to the United States that is not what he
is saying what he was referring to is
the class-based society that the poem
was meant to fight meaning that the poem
was meant according to Cuccinelli's
interpretation to specifically target
the class-based distinctions that he
felt were
that the poet felt were nonsensical in
Europe and should not be applied in the
United States
I mean people seem to ignore the part of
the of the poem on the Statue of Liberty
you know the part with the poor tired
huddled masses they exceed him to be
forgetting the phrase yearning to be
free yearning to be free is not the same
as yearning for free stuff that's why
there were public charge rules that were
on the books at the time and the Statue
of Liberty was built and that's the
point cuccinelli is making nonetheless
here's the headline immigration official
Ken Cuccinelli's from USA Today Statue
of Liberty poem refers to immigrants
from Europe he wasn't saying that the
only people who can immigrate to the
United States are from Europe he's
specifically talking about the literary
value and what it's referring to in
terms of class based systems he's not
saying that we can't have immigrants
from other places bethe work being the
dumb bleep that he is tweeted out this
administration finally admitted what
we've known all along they think the
Statue of Liberty only applies to white
people no that's that's now what he's
saying that's obviously not what he's
saying Josh Marshall again dishonest
says Cuccinelli that Statue of Liberty
poem was about people coming from Europe
again it was about the class-based
distinctions that we were attempting to
eradicate in the United States they're
classifying people based on class for
purposes of immigration it was a mistake
but not based on their inability to take
public welfare Washington Post opinion
columnist saying that he said the quiet
part out loud and all the rest of this
okay this is why it's its lack of
endemic trust that leads to this gap
between what people see as practicality
and moral character so for the left
because Donald Trump is Hitler and
because everybody on the right is
Hitlerian in intense and effect because
of all of that anything is justified
including line right we can just falsify
the data with regards to trump creating
a swath of violence across the country
we can simply falsify the data about
what ken cuccinelli actually said we can
simply make things up because all of
that is justified right if you're truly
moral as as AOC has said out loud if you
are truly moral the truth doesn't matter
only moral truth matters and that means
that you can simply make things up or
twist the truth to fit what you are
looking for and I criticize Trump
earlier for valuing what he sees as
practicality above moral character I
said these things do not have to be in
conflict in fact moral character can be
practical because it
is out the stakes of what is happening
but we seem to have abandoned this and
what that's led to is on the other side
of willingness to say okay well if you
guys aren't playing fair well then we're
not gonna play fair
practicality now demands that we abandon
moral character practicality demands
that we throw brick Bats at you
practicality demands that we cheer for a
person who confronts Chris Cuomo and
calls him Fredo in public practicality
demands that we be as mean as the other
side and it's immoral not to be as mean
as the other side so instead of morality
being used in service to practicality
and practicality morality buttressing
one another now more morality is
redefined to meet the needs of
practicality you're seeing it on the
left with the media coverage of the
Trump administration and you're seeing
it on the right with the cheering on of
activity that you would never tolerate
from people on the left and again well
if you think that politics is simply
warfare by other means than all is fair
in love and war but politics was not
supposed to be warfare by other means
not in a country where we were supposed
to share certain types of values this is
not supposed to be the point now it is
it is the reason why and it's so funny
because the left will will see this on
the right the left will see on the right
people who are religious people who are
backing Trump will say why are they
backing from how could they do this
despite Trump's myriad imbecilities and
despite the fact that Trump says bad
things all the time the reason is
because the right has made peace with
the idea that you guys are fighting a
battle and they're not going to be left
behind fighting a different battle
that's why the right is doing this now
is that the answer for the country's
woes no we actually need an armistice we
need both sides to come back to the
table and recognize that the practical
attempt to take down the other side by
any means necessary is really bad for
the country
then the war of all against all
everybody ends up dead this is a mistake
but I don't know how you expect the
people on the right to be the first to
go weapons down when it comes to
practical support for President Trump
when you guys are unfairly attacking
Trump from supporters as racists and
bigots as I've said a thousand times on
the show already and when when folks
talk about double standards the
alternative to double standards is not a
single standard
hey double standards are not standards
double standards are the evisceration of
standards and as we have this rate all
of our standards there's not a lot
that's gonna be left okay got to give
you a quick update on Jeffrey Epstein
here so Jeffrey Epstein I mean this is
just ridiculous it's ridiculous it would
make me suspicious except I always think
that people are morons I think that I
think the politics is veep it is not
house of cards so there is a report from
the New York Times on Tuesday apparently
both guards assigned to protect accused
sex trafficker Jeffrey Epstein fell
asleep while they were supposed to be
protecting him from himself both of them
both fell asleep how is that even
possible they didn't check on him for
three hours the guards and the warden
have now been removed the two employees
were placed on administrative leave the
warden was also reassigned pending the
outcome of the investigation the two
staff members apparently went to sleep
and then they falsified the logs they
falsely recorded in a log that they had
checked on the financier every 30
minutes as was required that is a
federal crime in fact the two people
guarding Epstein had been asleep for
some or all of the three hours according
to three of the officials insane run get
fodder to conspiracy theorists how about
you say both guards simply gave up and
went to sleep and then falsified the
logs afterward well done everyone I
think we should trust these folks about
health care don't you I really think
that everybody in government they're the
best and we should trust them to run our
economy we should trust them to run our
health care that's the only way really
to make everything all better
unbelievable
meanwhile the 2020 Democrats are getting
weirder and weirder actually New York
Mayor Bill DeBlasio is now engaging an
open conspiracy theorizing so remember
when it was a big deal that Trump did it
all de Blasio is now doing it openly he
was on Fox Business on Tuesday he said
it was too convenient that that Epstein
would commit suicide just as he was
about to implicate many other powerful
people he said quote this is way too
convenient this makes no sense he's one
of the most prominent prisoners in
America at that point he had even
attempted suicide previously or been
assaulted either way it's the same
reality he needed to be watched 24 hours
a day he said I'm not a conspiracy
theorist by nature but he said there's
no normal explanation
for all of this well I mean I will say
the de Blasio does have some experience
in getting away with the murder of
groundhogs so he really has some
expertise here perhaps we should listen
to him and other soup entities among the
20 20 Democrats we've got beta O'Rourke
relaunching his campaign with a speech
no one cares about Bill DeBlasio
crafting conspiracy theories about
Jeffrey Epstein and then we have
Elizabeth Warren who suggests that it's
time for Walmart employees to be paid
like the Walmart airs
you know the founders of Walmart she
tweeted out yesterday quote the Walmart
air is make four million dollars an hour
a new Walmart associate makes $11 an
hour my two cent wealth tax on families
like the Waltons would help level the
playing field for working families and
rebuild the middle class okay question
when has a new Walmart associate
employed 2.2 million people Walmart is
the single biggest employer in America
it is not close two point two million
people have their jobs through Walmart
yeah it seems to me that a new Walmart
associate should probably be paid less
than the person who bears the entire
financial risk for the future of a
company that employs 2.2 million people
seems to me that's that's probably
appropriate and we here at the Daily
wire got about a little under a hundred
employees you know who bears the risk of
insuring those people get paid every
month I do my business partner does our
investors do right we bear the risk
should we get paid more for bearing that
risk yeah we should probably pay get
paid more for bearing that risk
elizabeth warren implying that the stock
that the guy stocking the shelves at a
walmart should be paid the same as the
people who bear the risk for 2.2 million
workers and we we should put these folks
in charge honestly that they're the best
they're the smartest they're the wisest
and then we also have common-law harris
who by the way is is just a dud i mean
it is amazing how much of a dud she is
in politically right now the latest Real
Clear Politics poll average has dropped
iDEN still with a very wide lead in the
Real Clear Politics poll average for the
first time Elizabeth Warren has now
overtaken Bernie Sanders it is Joe Biden
30 Warren 19 Sanders 18 Harris all the
way down at 8 so Harris has fallen off
the map Warren and Sanders if they both
remain in the race then Biden clearly
wins the nomination on a primary level
but when you look at the primaries
things start to look a little bit
more interesting in Iowa there have been
pulls the Cho Biden up there was a poll
today that actually showed Bernie up in
New Hampshire so Biden is up in Iowa in
New Hampshire
Biden is basically running dead even
with Bernie and Warren is only trailing
by a little bit in South Carolina Biden
retains in extraordinarily widely
because he has a big lead among black
voters among white voters Warren is
actually winning in South Carolina but
something like 60% of the primary base
in South Carolina is black and Biden is
blowing everybody out among those voters
so Kamala Harris is getting desperate at
this point and she continues to try it
out promises that she can't keep she's
nobody should have to work more than one
job in the United States nobody should
have to work more
okay sure you know he's going around
crowing about how this economy is doing
so well right oh the economy is great he
says right and they refer to the
unemployment numbers well yeah I'm
traveling our country let me tell you
something yeah people are working
they're working two and three jobs and
in our America we must agree nobody
should have to work more than one job to
have a roof over their head and food on
the table okay well the fact is that if
you had to work more than one job to
have a roof over your head or food on
this table you probably shouldn't taken
the job that's not paying you enough
that'd be a you problem also it is not
true the vast majority of people in the
United States are working two jobs it
just is not true according to the census
statistics a small but steady number of
American workers have more than one job
because either they need extra income or
because they want to gain more
experience or explore different
interests there's a recently released US
Census Bureau report and apparently what
it found is that approximately eight
point three percent this is up as of
2013 so it's actually lower now eight
point three percent of workers had more
than one job that was as of 2013 it's a
lot lower now so this notion that there
are just tons and tons of people who are
working at multiple jobs it is not
really true it's not actually the
reality in May five percent of Americans
had multiple jobs five percent that's
really what's bringing down the
unemployment rate is
5% of workers who have multiple jobs
okay for all of the talk about people
working in uber it's it's held to that
range actually really since 2009 it's
always been a very very low number so
this again is just a lie it is also this
this bizarre idiocy that you can dictate
to the economy what the economy ought to
do every time everybody tries to dictate
to the economy what it ought to do the
economy fights back because it turns out
the aggregate knowledge of the market
economy knows more than you do I know
shocking Bernie Sanders starting get
desperate on his own and he has turned
against a new enemy and that is the
media now listen actually sympathize
with Bernie because I think that Bernie
got the beta o'rourke treatment in 2016
the media really pumped him up they
talked about what a wonderful brilliant
new thinker he was even though his ideas
were from CCNY circa 1932 and he got
that true and now they've turned on him
because there's a newer more attractive
Bernie in town by the name of Elizabeth
Warren which was how old the Democratic
Party that Elizabeth Warren is the new
or more attractive version of Bernie and
she's 70 Bernie Sanders has been going
after the media he's going after Jeff be
so sounding a lot like President Trump
he said so I think Jeff Basil's he's on
the phone
howling di-did the of the Washington
Post what to do absolutely not it does
not work that way and then he elaborated
and he said that nonetheless the media
have turned against them he says for
example I've been in politics for a few
years you know what not one reporter has
ever asked me Bernie what are you going
to do about the grotesque level of
income and wealth inequality are you
going to ask me that is that what the
part of what the media talks about um
yeah actually they asked you that all
the time Bernie because you're on the
left and you've gotten kid-glove
treatment but I feel bad for Bernie in
the sense that again
yeah the knees cut out from under him by
people he trusted which is sad for him
but again maybe do something productive
with your life for the first 80 years of
it before you decide to run for
president okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today I'm in the
middle of a biography of ulysses s grant
by Ron chernow there's been this really
interesting rethinking of grant as a
president the old story was that grant
was super corrupt is
grant himself at his administration was
plagued by corruption and crony
capitalism and that he was a really
ineffective president and now the
revised history basically suggests that
grant moving out of the presidency was a
horrible thing for the United States
because with the end of grants
presidents he really ended the
reconstruction efforts that could have
alleviated Jim Crow in the south that
the Radical Republican efforts to
reshape the south died with ulysses s
grant presidency and that it was
replaced by a willingness to go along to
get along with the Jim Crow South the
book does talk about that it talks about
grant as a characters really fascinating
an underrated character because
everybody sort of assumes that he was
just generic dolt who sort of stumbled
his way as a drunk into being the head
of All American forces during the Civil
War of the Union forces during the Civil
War not true the biography is very
detailed it's very long honestly the his
autobiography is shorter and probably
better but the biography is pretty good
by we're on sure now grant it's worth
checking out ok time for a quick thing
that I hate ok so there's been a lot of
talk in the last couple of weeks about
the Trump administration weakening the
Endangered Species Act the idea is that
the the Trump administration is going
out there and hunting bald eagles that
somewhere Trump is going out there with
a two to three think you know I'm gonna
bag me a baby today boom boom boom and
that's not what's going on here the
Endangered Species Act has been too
broadly applied generally speaking the
Endangered Species Act was applied under
the Obama administration to apply to
areas that once were used by animals but
no longer are or could be used by
animals in the future but are not being
used by those animals right now and what
that means is that the federal
government has been ruling off limits
more and more land there's a piece back
in 2000 in 2013 by David Vitter senator
from Louisiana in which he talked about
the Obama administration using the
Endangered Species Act in order to
basically Trump Trump and trample on
local authorities and the ability of
businesspeople to do their business
he said Obama's policy makers often act
nefariously through a tactic called sue
and settle they settle litigation with
their allies and environmental groups
behind closed doors
in a way that advances their far-left
agenda blocking out of the process those
citizens states and local governments
affected by their decisions and their
subsequent rules and regulations so
here's how it works one or more far-left
environmental groups through the federal
government in this case under the
Endangered Species Act claiming that the
government is not satisfying its
regulatory obligations then the groups
and their friends in the administration
draft the settlement agreement
completely behind closed doors he says
this tactic has led to extreme and
abusive actions very near where I live
in Louisiana there Washington
bureaucrats are telling a private
landowner his land cannot be used in any
commercial way thus driving its value
down to near zero this is all to protect
the dusky gopher frog a species that's
alive and well in Mississippi but has
literally not been spotted in that part
of Louisiana for nearly 50 years
hey that so what is the new Trump ruling
that is apparently so terrible well new
rules will allow the administration of
this according to Washington Post to
reduce the amount of habitat set aside
for wildlife and remove tools that
officials use to predict future harm to
species as a result of climate change so
basically what this this new thing does
it says you're using these estimates of
where these species are going to inhabit
fifty years from now in order to rule
out of use land right now and we're
gonna instead look at economic impact on
that we're gonna start taking economic
impact into account which should be part
of the conversation
economics is merely the study of
trade-offs and pretending that there are
no trade-offs when you ban the use of
land to preserve the dusky gopher frog
that is in Mississippi but not in
Louisiana that's a mistake Wilbur Ross
the Commerce Secretary said the
revisions finalized with this rulemaking
fits squarely within the president's
mandate of easing the regulatory burden
on the American public without
sacrificing our species protection and
recovery goals of course the left is
reacting by suggesting that this is an
attempt to destroy endangered species
under the administration's new rules it
would have been nearly impossible to
designate the polar bear is threatened
in 2010 because of the loss of sea ice
in the Arctic one of the fastest warming
areas in the world nearly 200,000 square
miles of barrier islands in Alaska were
listed as critical habitat officials
relied on climate models to predict how
warming would impact polar bear habitat
more than 80 years into the future
the new rule is called such predictions
in doubt and said officials can now only
determine impacts in what it described
vaguely as the foreseeable future ok
well this is true I'm sorry that this
happens to be the case
it happens to be the case that as the
projections move further and further out
there are less and less certain with
regard to climate change in the impact
on species I remember there was talk
about opening the the Arctic National
Wildlife Refuge to drilling and how this
is going to drive down the caribou
population instead it turns out that the
caribou blights the heat from the
pipelines and so they go there to mates
there are lots more caribou if all of
this were simple as simple and
predictable as environmentalists wish
that it were it would be a lot easier
the new rules limit the area of land
that can be protected to help species
recover and survive
currently land that plants and animals
occupy is set aside for their protection
in addition to areas they once occupied
or might need in the future could it get
any bigger than that now critical
habitat that is not occupied might not
be protected opening it up for other
forms of development also a rule change
stripped away language that said that
the secretary that the Commerce
Secretary and the Interior Secretary
shall make a listing determination
solely on the basis of the best
scientific and commercial information
regarding a species status regardless of
cost well now they can look at the
economic impact of a listing well that
makes a lot more sense again these are
trade offs to pretend that trade offs do
not exist is incredibly stupid but the
way that we are treating this is as
though there are no trade offs but this
is not Trump saying okay go out and hunt
the whales that's that's the way that
the the media are covering this is Trump
saying free reign on the permafrost in
the whale that is not what this rule
does and that is simply dishonest okay
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content stay tuned or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]